lá hum
[Música]
eu acredito muito no na mágica que a
arte tem acredito que a arte é a coisa
mais mágica que a gente tem na sociedade
se imaginar quando você se colocar no
lugar daquele cara nas cavernas que não
conhecia nenhuma imagem e que de repente
ele pega uma pedra e daí ele marca uma
parede e descobre que a marca fica lá o
espaço tempo ele continua marcando ele
descobre o desenho e ele descobre que
ele consegue alguma maneira gravar ali a
história dele avalia os momentos mais
importantes da vida dele e quando alguém
olha cara da caverna do lado ele olha a
morro que isso eu consigo ver você ali
mesmo depois que ele morre
ele ainda continua vivo naquela imagem
arte essa coisa muito mágica ea
tecnologia ela é por outro lado essa
coisa que faz a gente avançar demais mas
a gente mudar toda hora e né da caverna
pra cá mudou bastante mas acho que vocês
vão concordar comigo que tem mudado mais
tem mudado mais rápido e essa mudança
rápida que está acontecendo faz com que
coisas na nossa vida nosso dia a dia
mudei muito então por exemplo há dez
anos atrás
você sabia o telefone de várias pessoas
saber se deve imaginar algum tempo e
relembrar de sua mãe talvez a namorada
ser de alguma é acenava para chamar o
táxi
talvez daqui a alguns não muitos anos
alguém vai dar risada de que talvez você
goste ainda de dirigir seu carro você
mesmo
então essas a tecnologia transforma
demais as coisas porque ela propõe pra
gente um monte de respostas coisas
importantes respostas importantes que a
gente quer para transformar nossa vida e
é nesse contexto que eu acredito que as
perguntas passam a ser mais e mais
relevante
a tecnologia pode nos entregar muitas
respostas
quais são as perguntas que a gente quer
responder eu acredito muito que a arte é
a sensibilidade da arte aliada com o
poder da tecnologia o poder de
transformação que ela tem ela pode criar
o futuro mais humano que a gente quer
para o nosso mundo
então eu queria contar pra vocês duas
histórias histórias é que são
relacionadas com duas perguntas que
foram feitas pra mim e que de alguma
maneira é trouxeram e criaram os
projetos mais importantes que já me
envolvi
a primeira história é a primeira
pergunta é isso é a tecnologia ela
afasta o aproxima as pessoas que você
acha
com certeza já pensou nisso a tecnologia
ela às vezes penso em você ela se afasta
ou te aproxima das pessoas foi baseada
nessa pergunta que o coletivo amor de
madre comissão é uma galeria de arte em
são paulo comissionou a a minha empresa
que eu tenho com meu sócio joão tac e se
a gente tinha 17 anos começaram a gente
pra criar uma instalação artística que
explorar essa ideia na tecnologia pasta
ela aproxima as pessoas
a gente criou isso a instalação é feita
de madeira feita de vidro e fita de
tecnologia transparente
essa que vocês estão vendo ela estava a
foi montada na china em pequim
e essa outra vez também foi montada aqui
no brasil em são paulo
a proposta dessa instalação é bem
simples
o que a gente queria era fazer com que
uma pessoa pudesse tocar outra pessoa do
outro lado do mundo
funcionava assim você e até esse lugar
né
gostava nesse vidro se você encostar se
nesse vidro no mesmo ponto e ao mesmo
momento que outra pessoa do outro lado
do mundo
vocês dois sentiam
tinham se tocado
essa experiência foi uma experiência
extremamente transformadora pra mim
porque de alguma maneira as pessoas que
viveram essa experiência elas sentiam
realmente que tinham tocado em alguém
depois de fazer essa experiência em são
paulo e na china a gente foi convidado
para fazer essa experiência também em
dubai a conectar do lado novo eo antigo
da cidade do bairro e usar a dizer são
um povo incrivelmente sinceramente
diversos muito diferente da gente onde
diferentes dos chineses muito diferente
de nós
uma das coisas que é muito diferente é
como as mulheres se comportam na
sociedade as mulheres elas não tocam e
nenhum homem em aperto de mão e nenhuma
em câncer e seu marido ou alguém da sua
família então podia imaginar o que era
essa instalação artística um centro da
nova da nova do vai e da do bairro
antiga
muitas mulheres quando quando a gente se
aplicava para elas como a estação
funcionava elas iam lá de alguma maneira
estavam aquilo mas muitas delas era
muito interessante ver isso muitas delas
fugiu da experiência quando descobriu
que elas podiam tocar um estranho se é
realmente muito louco é comum é como
aquela imagem na caverna
ela tinha um poder tão forte que ela
inserida na verdade a realidade daquelas
pessoas e esse é o poder à tarde
esse projeto essa janela ela ela era ela
tinha essa é a característica de textos
e desenhos muito diferentes em cada
janela tinha um padrão
era feita a partir da localização dessa
janela no mapa
então como funcionava a gente criou esse
algoritmo baseado nas clássicas de 9
chinesas e das machas sabias que pegava
a latitude ea longitude do lugar e
criava esses desenhos que eram sempre
muito diferentes para cada lugar do
mundo
escrava como se fosse uma identidade
para aquela aquela aquela instalação que
tinha ver exatamente com aquele lugar
onde ela estava e quando a gente quando
a gente avançou nesse projeto quando as
coisas aconteceram para ele a gente
entendeu que rendeu muitas coisas
interessantes sobre toque sobre
intimidades sobre tecnologia ea gente
resolveu que queria falar mais disso a
gente resolveu que a gente queria falar
mais sobre a tecnologia afastava o
aproximar das pessoas
então a gente fez o site fez um vídeo
disso mostrou que as pessoas tinham um
certo impacto mas a gente queria mais
queria ter alguma maneira fazer com que
mais pessoas pudessem experience ar
aquele toque que a gente pense ou quando
a gente estava lá tocando uma pessoa do
outro lado do mundo que ia falar mais
sobre isso e aqui talvez foi a primeira
vez que ouvi essas duas coisas se unindo
de uma forma tão tão mágica que é a arte
ea sensibilidade da arte junto com o
poder de transformação da tecnologia nos
negócios
os produtos serviços que a gente usa
todo dia a gente decidiu que a gente ia
fazer alguma coisa que fosse diretamente
nessa direção alguma coisa que toda
pessoa pudesse ter se ela quisesse
experimentar essa sensação essa
experiência então a gente decidiu que
quer um mobiliário e decidiu que a gente
criar esse banco né porque o banco era
essa coisa mais simples que era a
primeira coisa que a gente podia fazer
ele era para duas pessoas então os
bancos lugar de duas pessoas podem se
juntar as pessoas podem interagir com um
lugar para se conectar a gente partiu da
idéia de fazer um banco convencional que
duas pessoas se sentam e daí pra ajudar
ela se tocar né encostar um pouco mais
de diminuir um pouco as medidas ajudará
elas um pouco além disso trava nesse
banco que ajudava as pessoas se
conectarem entre si
a gente queria aqui cada banco fosse
único assim como cada janela era a única
e como cada experiência de encostar em
albin de tocar em alguém é muito unido
então o que a gente fez foi que criou
essa interface que de um lado você
coloca você escolhe no mapa o lugar que
você nasceu e do outro lado você escolhe
o lugar onde a pessoa que você ama
nasceu daí no meio você consegue ver
esses dois padrões se unindo e formando
a base o que é esse banco depois com
processos de produção digital snc
a gente faz é o banco que ele é
costurado na cada um desses lados é
costurado como esse relacionamento esse
toque está sendo costurado e a gente
entrega professor e agora pergunta a
tecnologia ela deixa as pessoas mais
perto ou deixa as pessoas mais tons
primeira pergunta
a segunda pergunta é um outro projeto eu
quero mostrar pra vocês é uma pergunta
talvez muito mais difícil que essa eu
vou precisar de vocês para responder que
vocês pensassem a pessoa que vocês amam
a pessoa que vier à cabeça que nós
fizemos muito pai sua mãe o marido e sua
esposa seu filho se eu pedisse pra você
imaginar essa sensação esse amor criar
uma forma para esse amor
agora que forma esse amor tem que forma
têm o amor
então essa pergunta que forma tem um
amor ela é foi o drive da cidade de uma
pesquisa
em mais de três anos que é de 3 na
empresa fazendo junto com o estúdio guto
requena esse projeto chamado love
project
a ideia é criar objetos de design a
partir de histórias de amor
então em vez de em vez de a gente
desenhar como eu pedi pra vocês fazerem
desenhar na nossa cabeça qualquer forma
do amor que a gente fez foi a gente
desenha um processo pelo qual a gente
pudesse passar por essa forma acontecer
então o que é com o processo que a gente
deseja foi o seguinte com um chamava
pessoas
essas pessoas vinham lá para um espaço
que a gente criou é de vestir ela com
vários sensores sensores de ondas
cerebrais sensores de batimento cardíaco
e que o fone para vós ea gente deixava
sozinha e pediu que ela contará a maior
história de amor da vida dela enquanto
ela estava contando essa história a
gente sair da sala e olhava pra esses
gráficos e entendia como que ela estava
se emocionando no decorrer dessa
história que pegava então esses gráficos
criavam um objeto de forma dinâmica e
imprimir a ele numa impressora 3d
essa é a idéia bom como ela experimenta
o experimento artístico experimento
humano para chegar na forma do amor a
gente não fazia muita idéia do que é
sair os primeiros
os primeiros testes foram vamos assim
caóticos depois
além de códigos e leis como começar a
ser mais mínimo expressivos
eles tinham alguma coisa ele tinha
alguma coisa que a gente conseguia ver
que é interessante mas ao mesmo tempo
num mesmo tempo deixava o quebra-quebra
principalmente original acho que essa é
a palavra
daí quando em quando a gente estava
fazendo isso a gente olhou pra isso foi
o que ele quis avançar nesses valores
que avançou bastante pesquisou monte
chegou e foi avançando avançando até que
a gente chegou no lugar de gente olhou
para ela
se for talvez aqui a gente tem uma forma
então a gente começou então a a desenhar
o que foi o nosso maior a nossa maior
performance até o momento 50 pessoas que
a gente convidou uma galeria de arte em
são paulo
e aí a galera aberta qualquer pessoa
pode laje tem muitos visitantes 50
convidados que contar suas histórias de
amor com todos os sensores ea gente
fazia ao vivo esta performance a gente
ouvia as histórias de amor é mostrar os
sentimentos plantados nas telas e ter as
impressoras 3d lac é um é imprimir os
objetos essas formas que representavam a
história de amor de cada uma dessas
pessoas
o resultado foi o que a gente achou
ficou extremamente feliz com o estado
foram essas 53 mandalas que são geradas
de um único algoritmo todas elas
elas são extremamente únicas assim como
cada uma tem sua própria individualidade
mas ao mesmo tempo elas fazem parte de
um único todo e ficou claro pra gente
quando isso acabou
a gente tinha alguma coisa ali a gente
percebeu que a gente tinha ali é que o
amor em múltiplas formas e que ele podia
ser representada de múltiplas formas
então a gente fez foi a gente avançou
nesse projeto
da mesma maneira que a gente fez no
anterior
a gente queria espalhar essa ideia é
essa coisa que a gente pense ou pro
mundo aqui a gente queria fazer a mesma
coisa queria dar para mais pessoas mais
do que aquela 50 a possibilidade de ver
qualquer forma qual que é essa
o desenho da sua história de amor dos
sentimentos da sua história de amanhã é
um pra fazer isso não é pra tanto de
novo para transformar uma coisa que era
pequena que estava lá no museu para
entregá-la para o mundo a gente foi a
tecnologia e produtos digitais
a gente decidiu que a gente ia
transformar love pode
o digital então o desafio gigante a
gente foi atrás de parceiros pessoas
para nos ajudar com logística com outras
coisas é com impressão produção ea gente
encontrou esse nosso sócio que era um
cara muito bom de produção 3d e ele
entrou
eduardo dias entrou como sócio então
ficou de 3 o estudo requena eduardo dias
criaram então a junção desses três que
era então o aura que é a a evolução do
do lobby pró dilma
o aura é muito simples é realmente muito
simples é um aplicativo está disponível
e pode baixar um aplicativo que vai que
transforma histórias de amor em objectos
de design
esse aplicativo ele guia você de forma
calma e tranquila pra contar sua
história de amor e usa seu nome o
microfone do seu celular pra captar sua
voz e usa também o seu dedo e o a câmera
e flash de seu celular para captar os
seus batimentos cardíacos
muitas pessoas falam que isso é sujeira
na pista que não funciona mas é verdade
funciona porque os todo seu corpo pulsa
junto com seu coração inclusive a ponta
de seu dedo
então eu trouxe até aqui ó isso aqui é o
que a câmera consegue ver tamanha que a
câmera consegue ver do seu dedo quando
seu coração está pulsando o nosso
aplicativo ele faz é ele olha para a
imagem processa imagens transforma isso
em um batimento cardíaco para depois
gerar esse desenho único que é o desenho
da sua da sua história de amor
depois com um programa com tecnologia de
projeção digital principalmente
impressão 3d
a gente cria uma mandala de ouro que
representa a forma do seu amor
essa aqui
a minha história é o amor da minha vida
bom de novo é o aurora na verdade ele
lhe entrega isso de novo e reforce de
novo que é a mensagem o que eu realmente
queria dizer que é a sensibilidade da
arte aliada com poder da tecnologia nos
negócios negócios produtos e serviços
principalmente digitais têm poder de
transformar o mundo e ele já tá criando
os negócios do futuro e o melhor disso é
que já em cada um de nós dentro de cada
um de nós nossos sentimentos mais
humanos
as nossas intenções mais simples e
nossos sentimentos mais humanos
o poder pra criar esse futuro de todos
nós precisamos usá lo muito bem obrigado
[Aplausos]